when I tell people I'm a biologist they
often think of state-of-the-art labs
electron microscopes advanced computers
but actually a lot of my work looks more
similar to that of a 19th century
naturalist Victorian biologists like
Alfred Russel Wallace traveled all over
the world with little more than a
butterfly net some vials and the bottle
of spirits in those days
biology meant collecting preserving
describing and classifying anything you
could find and 160 years later some
things haven't changed a bit
together with my colleague MacLean like
him I recently led an expedition to
Mount Kinabalu in Borneo following in
Wallace's footsteps we worked with
insect and bird nets plant presses and
lots and lots of tubes jars and flasks
for anything from tiny spiders to bits
of giant rainforest tree our aim was to
study endemic species found only on the
mountain and nowhere else on earth when
Wallace visited Borneo in 1855 he saw
that endemic species like these were
always found near similar-looking loanin
creatures suggesting that one had
evolved from the other and we now know
that he was right our question is how
and where this evolution took place
fortunately we have a few more tools at
our disposal than Wallace did we took
DNA samples from every species we
collected from flies and leeches to
mushrooms and orchids so we could work
out how all the species are related to
each other where they came from and when
they evolve and that's knowledge that
Wallace could only have dreamed of as it
turns out the endemic species on the
cool mountain summit had evolved not
only from nearby lowland species but
also from species that had drifted in
from distant mountains or COO
in either case most of these ancestors
were already adapted to high altitudes
or cold climates so they only had to
make small adjustments to their new
niche which means that we don't know how
well this vulnerable mountain
biodiversity will be able to cope with
the speed of modern climate change while
Wallace and his fellow explorers set out
only to catalogue an ecosystem today we
have far more specific questions but the
methods of the Victorian naturalist
still serve as well and future
biologists may well continue wielding
the same butterfly nets the question is
whether all these unique mountain
species will still be there for them to
catch